bài lần trước khi tải Anti-Gravity Mình, Đây mình đã convert,
mình đã bảo con AntiGravity để trả lời file Excel của mình
Và tự động tạo một bản Excel mới Đây là bản
Excel mới Bây giờ mình sẽ dùng con Gemini của mình và sử dụng
skill của Excel để xem kết quả xem thế nào nha. Đây
là file nó đã tinh chỉnh lại.
Đó. Không còn lỗi nữa,
Chào các bạn, hôm nay mình sẽ làm về AI văn phòng tập 3.
Tập trước mình đã dùng skill của anh Ivan để tạo một skill cơ
bản về Word cho con AI của mình. Hôm nay mình sẽ dùng skill
khác của anh về Excel. Kỹ năng này của anh đang được hơn 60.000
người tải xuống và sử dụng. Nếu bạn thấy hay,
hãy like, share, subscribe để mình có thêm động lực làm những video tiếp
theo nha. Ok, mình đã dùng ClawCode để tóm tắt xem kỹ năng này
của anh sẽ có gì nào. Đây
là mình đã dùng tóm tắt kỹ năng của anh Mình hỏi con ClawCode
là hãy tóm tắt kỹ năng này, skill này được không?
Và đây là bản tóm tắt của con ClawCode Mục đích của skill này
là hỗ trợ đọc và chỉnh sửa file Excel với độ chính xác cao
về công thức, định dạng và ngày tháng và cấu trúc của workbook,
Khi nào dùng và khi làm việc với Excel, đặc biệt là khi cần
có những công thức, định dạng,
ô ghép hoặc là cần tương thích đa nền tảng.
7 quy tắc cốt lõi. Đầu tiên là chọn công cụ đúng mục đích.
Phải dùng Pandas để cho phân tích dữ liệu và OpenPyXL khi cần
công thức hoặc là style hoặc là ghép.
Ngày tháng, số serial, được lưu dưới dạng số nguyên,
bắt đầu từ 1900 nên cần xử lý cẩn thận.
Giữ công thức trong Excel, không hardcode.
Tất cả công thức phải được viết từ những công thức từ Excel để
workbook còn sống. Bảo vệ dữ liệu,
số điện thoại, mã zip. Nên định dạng dưới dạng text thì Excel
có thể tự cắt số quá 15 chữ số.
Giữ nguyên cấu trúc của workbook, không thay đổi style,
thứ tự sheet, vùng in,
filter. Có những yêu cầu tính toán lại trước khi giao.
Open Excel không tự tính toán công thức kiểm tra lại không còn lỗi
và tối ưu cho file lớn.
Đó. Và anh cũng đưa ra một số 7 bẫy phổ biến về Excel
tự động. Chuyển đổi ID thành số dạng khác và lưu sai chế độ
có thể làm mất công thức. Google Sheets hoặc LibreOffice có thể hiển
thị khác các hàm mới. Và đó là skill của anh.
Anh ấy chỉ chia sẻ một số quy tắc và bẫy về
Excel. Và mình đã tải skill này về
Anti-Gravity và mình đã lưu ở dưới dạng đây.
Đây là skill của anh ấy trên trang web mà mình vừa copy về.
Đó. Rồi mình chỉ bảo con AntiGravity của mình là Bạn
có thể skill Excel này thành một skill trên AI Folder để mỗi khi
mình tạo hoặc chỉnh sửa file Excel, mình đều dùng skill này và mình
làm y hệt với Word. Thì nó sẽ update cái rule
của mình và cursor rule của mình để mỗi khi mình hoàn thành bất
kỳ thao tác nào với Excel thì nó sẽ đọc cái skill của
anh Ivan này trước. Trước khi bắt đầu làm.
Ok, hãy đến với demo nha.
Mình, à,
Trong lần trước mình có một, à,
Ở giữa bài lần trước khi tải Anti-Gravity Mình,
Đây mình đã convert, mình đã bảo con AntiGravity
để trả lời file Excel của mình Và tự động tạo một bản
Excel mới Đây là bản Excel mới Bây
giờ mình sẽ dùng con Gemini của mình và sử dụng skill của Excel
để xem kết quả xem thế nào nha. Bây
giờ mình sẽ bảo con Excel của mình là tạo một file khác
file khác, file Excel khác,
để,
Từ file cũ của mình xem kết quả sẽ thế nào.
Ok, con Gemini Pro 3 của mình đã hoàn thành xong.
Và đây là một số lỗi mà nó phát hiện ra từ skill mới
của anh. Phân biệt vạch đỏ công thức,
input vào công thức. Đó, chỉnh sửa một số lỗi về formula công thức
này. Đó, và giao diện định dạng,
nó formatting lại xem nó đẹp hơn không. Mình chưa mở ra nên là
mình chưa biết. Ok, hãy mở ra xem file này xem thế nào nha.
Excel tinh chỉnh. Đó.
Đây là file nó đã tinh chỉnh lại.
Đó. Không còn lỗi nữa,
không còn bị lỗi như file lần trước nữa.
Đây là mình chỉ cần, Đó,
tại vì số dài quá.
Đó. Những số serial number.
Và đó là skill của anh Ivan.
Nó đã chỉnh sửa lại format đẹp hơn và sửa một số lỗi từ
bản cũ. Thank you for watching.